hey guys back at Roseanne's kitchen
table and I am with my favorite even
Jacqueline Glenn I you've religion
hating God come on Jacqueline Glenn
really that's what it says you know I
put your name in YouTube that's why I
wanted to bring here ok because I put
your name in youtube I put Jacqueline
Glenn interesting stuff in YouTube and
then I hit the space button and you know
what came up Jesus loves loves God know
that hates glass person ever hates God
Jacqueline Glenn hates God that's what
came up why why do you hate God why do
you think I did what I want to know but
I have so we became friends about six
months ago you come out and show a bunch
we do a lot of atheists stuff together
we do a lot of the religious stuff and
we talked about religious extremism and
all that stuff but why would Jacqueline
Glen hates God don't hate because I
think I get a lot of people responding
to my videos and whenever you are
critical of religion and a lot of times
people interpret that as a hatred for
you know whatever deity they happen to
believe in and that's not really my
fault but that's just the reaction that
I get alone I'm sure you get into I you
know get it why do people think I hate
everything I hate women I hate gays I
was just gonna [ __ ] with it how do you
hate me I don't know everything I hate
yeah so you think it's not so you've
never said anything that would imply
that you hate God but you hate sort of
the dogma that's attached to it oh yeah
yeah i mean III do definitely feel like
religion is poison but that doesn't mean
that i hate sound bike oh yeah there we
go religion is poison but that doesn't
mean that i hate God because I always
say this you can't hate something that
you don't think is real so you know
that's the trick ah that's it no I was
looking at some of your videos and one
of the things that I'm very I've been
saying this a lot lately but I'm very
proud of that on our channel our
comments are like ninety percent about
what we're doing and they're very like
whether they agree with us or not like
you guys are really great and it's about
the topics now I note that you because
you do more about religion that tends to
bring out the crazies sewer vault does
yes definitely true but I mean you know
religion has been associated with crazy
for a long time so not surprising but ya
know I like you're not pulling any
punches no you know
why yeah what's up my lap but ya know I
get a lot of interesting comments but I
like that because it generates
discussion and that's the point of doing
this yeah so how do the atheists the
Atheist community atheists how do the
atheists the heathen you know how do
they sort of get together with the god
people and all not hate each other
because that's what I what I see
constantly is just this is hateful it's
not it shouldn't be though yeah I mean I
I'm friends with and have great
relationships with people who are
religious my family for example you know
there's nothing you know wrong with
being able to be with other people or
hang out with people who think
differently than you it's that way in
politics I have friends who are
Republicans yeah but you know no
seriously like why is it that you can
disagree with people in politics and
that's like more acceptable than
disagree with people in religion or
anything really that's an interesting
point so I guess well you can't really
disagree people in politics anywhere
everyone seems to be fighting about
everything all times maybe that is more
to do with its not taking us personally
right yeah I mean right so your family
is yeah is religious their religious
ahead of a feeling I mean we we are
civil you know we try to avoid it yeah
the most part because it sometimes
feelings can get hurt because I you know
they feel like it's kind of a letdown
that I'm not agreeing with them on
certain things that I was raised to
agree with but I mean for the most part
you know they're okay with it they still
love me you know I haven't been outcast
um do you think it's harder for female
atheists then for men I don't like
making everything about like the
man-woman thing but I feel like yeah
total at total sex is too that's what
they say also but I feel like there's
some like for a girl to be more
outspoken yeah shunned upon more so now
if you say you're an atheist it's like
doubling down yeah I have a lot of
friends online who are guys and they get
a lot of hate to I think the difference
is that sometimes women are more you
know emotionally taken aback by that
kind of thing they're they're kind of
afraid to put themselves out there
because they know they're going to get
backlash and you know they take it more
personally than guys do for me I've just
been doing
so long that I've built up a thick skin
and I'm trying to encourage other girls
to go out and do the same thing but you
know it's kind of hard girls tend to
care more about what people think of
them which is something I'm trying to
change don't care well I know you're not
bullshitting because you have building
up a thick skin we're going to talk
about some of the interactions that go
out on youtube and somebody to do it a
little bit anyway do you guys hate God
do you love God you hate God how do we
end the YouTube video thanks for
watching make sure to give this video
thumbs up share it everywhere subscribe